Okay, so there are these polls that become
more and more popular the closer we get to
the primaries and eventually to election day
and they are called hypothetical match-ups.
If the Democratic nominee were, would you
vote for Biden or Trump?
If the Democratic nominee were Bernie Sanders
or Elizabeth Warren, would you vote for Bernie
or Warren or would you vote for Donald Trump?
And the idea is to start getting an assessment,
not just of who's popular within the Democratic
primary, but who might fare better in the
general election against Donald Trump.
Now all the normal caveats and disclaimers
have to be applied.
We are still, uh, what is it, 14 months out
from the election.
Uh, these are not going to be a necessarily
the same numbers that we would get in November
of 2020.
Um, they still don't account for what would
potentially take place geo politically and
domestically between now and the election.
But it's an idea.
It gives us a sense of sort of where things
are with some of these hypothetical matchups.
CNN did the most deceptive thing where they
put up the results, the results out of order,
which just so happened to make Bernie Sanders
look far weaker than he actually is.
So first I'm going to play the clip from CNN,
then we'll look more closely at the images.
And the important thing to know is that this
is information from a Quinnipiac poll, and
according to this Quinnipiac poll, the Democrat
with the biggest lead against Trump is Biden.
Biden is plus 16 over Trump in this poll.
Now, it doesn't matter whether you believe
it or not, because the point is, is CNN accurately
representing the results?
Biden is plus 16.
Bernie is plus 14 over Trump and Warren is
plus 12, meaning Bernie is second in terms
of the size of his lead, uh, against Trump
and hypothetical match up in this poll.
Let's take a look at the CNN clip
and large lead fee for all of the Democratic
Front runners there.
Uh, tell us what this news means for the president.
How seriously are they taking these numbers?
I mean, w what Harry was pointing to with
the economy.
I think that, I mean, that
number is problematic for sure for the president.
Okay, so now let's look at the way that they
show the results on screen.
Remember the order is Biden plus 16, Bernie
Plus 14, Warren plus 12, but for whatever
reason they show Biden, then Warren and then
Sanders.
Now they're not lying about the numbers.
When you look at the numbers, the numbers
have the right numbers, but why is it in this
order?
And then you'll notice over to the right side
of the screen are Harris and Buddha judge
who have even smaller leads over Trump and
Warren in the hypothetical poll.
So this is not a story where I want to talk
about how much is a hypothetical poll worth
in August of the year before the election.
This is not me wanting to talk about is Biden
gaining or falling or can we believe that
Biden is plus 16 over Trump?
All I'm talking about is this is a data point
and the question is how is it that CNN came
up with this order for how they displayed
the results?
No matter whether you're displaying the results
in two columns or in two rows alphabetically,
there is no way that Bernie Sanders would
be at the bottom of the screen, even in alphabetical
order.
Bernie with a B Sanders with an s, he would
not be at the bottom of the screen.
His lead is bigger than Warren's.
His lead is bigger than common-law Harris's
is lead is bigger than Pete.
Buddha judges.
His first name starts with a B. His last name
starts with an s.
There is no explanation for why Bernie Sanders
name is at the bottom of the screen.
Now do I think that this is a deliberate attack
on Bernie Sanders by CNN?
I Dunno.
Honestly, not really.
I know people are saying, Oh, CNN is now choosing
Warren.
They've anointed Warren as the Non Biden person
that they're going to promote.
Maybe, Eh, I don't know that it's that calculated,
but it just always seems to not quite work
out in Bernie Sanders favor in these things.
Maybe there's some deliberate nature to it.
Either way, whether it's on purpose, negligence,
indifference in competence.
It's another one of these subliminal digs
at Bernie Sanders.
Bernie at the bottom of the screen, even though
the numbers say he's actually right there
behind Biden and ahead of everybody else in
a hypothetical match up against Donald Trump.
Trump.
The other thing is that, okay, the graphics
person at CNN made the graphic, the producer
potentially approved the graphic, or maybe
even the producer directed the graphics person
about how it should be made, but the anchor
Jim shooto could also have noticed that, hey,
this thing is out of order and could have
pointed it out.
And Jim Shuto either doesn't notice which
is concerning or decides not to point it out,
which means he's complicit in the entire thing.
I'm truly lame, very amateurish, and again,
whether it's deliberate or not, it always
seems to end up subliminally making Bernie
Sanders look worse.
Let me know what you think about this.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at [inaudible]
David Pakman show.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
as well at David's dot cocky the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com